Narrator:
WELCOME TO THE SHARK TANK,
WHERE ENTREPRENEURS
SEEK AN INVESTMENT
TO START, GROW, OR SAVE
THEIR BUSINESS.
LAST YEAR, WE ACTUALLY DID
$5.7 MILLION IN SALES.
WHOA.
WHOO!
NOT SO FUNNY ANYMORE.
Narrator: IF THE SHARKS HEAR
A GREAT IDEA...
[ LAUGHS ]
...THEY'LL INVEST
THEIR OWN MONEY...
I ACTUALLY COULD LEARN
FROM YOU.
...AND FIGHT EACH OTHER
FOR A DEAL.
I'LL GIVE YOU THE $600,000
FOR 15%.
I CAN GUARANTEE YOU THE DEVIL
WOULD GIVE YOU A BETTER DEAL.
Narrator: BUT THE ENTREPRENEURS
MUST GET THE FULL AMOUNT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR, OR THEY'LL
WALK AWAY WITH NOTHING.
I SEE YOU GUYS GOING
DOWN THE TOILET RIGHT NOW.
YOU'RE ABOUT TO
LOSE EVERYTHING.
WOULD YOU CONSIDER 40%?
NO.
DAMN IT.
Narrator:
WHO ARE THE SHARKS?
THEY'RE SELF-MADE
BUSINESS EXPERTS WORTH BILLIONS.
KEVIN O'LEARY IS A SHREWD
VENTURE CAPITALIST
WHO MADE HIS FORTUNE
SELLING A CHILDREN'S
EDUCATIONAL COMPANY
FOR OVER $4 BILLION.
DAYMOND JOHN DOMINATED
THE FASHION WORLD WITH FUBU.
NOW HE'S THE BRANDING EXPERT
BEHIND MULTIPLE GLOBAL BRANDS
GENERATING BILLIONS IN SALES.
ROBERT HERJAVEC, SON OF
AN IMMIGRANT FACTORY WORKER,
FOUNDED ONE OF
THE WORLD'S PREEMINENT
CYBER-SECURITY FIRMS.
LORI GREINER, THE QUEEN OF QVC,
HOLDS OVER 100 PATENTS
AND HAS LAUNCHED
OVER 400 PRODUCTS,
GROSSING OVER A HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS IN SALES.
AND MARK CUBAN,
RENOWNED BILLIONAIRE TECH MOGUL
AND THE OUTSPOKEN OWNER
OF THE DALLAS MAVERICKS.
FIRST INTO THE TANK
ARE ENTREPRENEURS
WHO BELIEVE THEY HAVE
THE NEXT BIG THING IN TOYS.
HELLO, SHARKAROOS.
I'M RACHEL McMURTREY.
AND I'M STEVE McMURTREY.
AND WE ARE
THE PROUD OWNERS OF...
THE JUNGLE JUMPAROO.
A BETTER WAY TO BOUNCE.
WE ARE ASKING FOR $100,000
FOR 20% EQUITY OF OUR COMPANY.
OUR TOY
IS BOTH UNIQUE AND FUN,
AND THERE'S NOTHING
ON THE MARKET LIKE IT.
TO SHOW YOU HOW FUN IT IS,
LET'S SEE IT IN ACTION.
COME ON, KIDS.
COME ON, GUYS.
COME ON. COME ON.
COME ON! WHOO!
COME ON,
COME ON, COME ON.
YEAH! WHOO-HOO!
John: SHE GETTING SOME AIR.
LOOK AT THAT.
YEAH!
Steve: LET'S SEE
HOW HIGH YOU CAN JUMP.
HEY!
WHO CAN JUMP THE HIGHEST?
WHOO!
WHOO-HOO!
WHOA.
YEAH!
LOOKS REALLY FUN.
THAT'S A BROKEN ANKLE
WAITING TO HAPPEN.
ALL RIGHT, KIDS.
LET'S BOUNCE ON OUT OF HERE.
AAH!
YEAH, COME ON. LET'S BOUNCE.
RUN, RUN, RUN.
[ LAUGHS ]
AWW.
Rachel: [ LAUGHS ]
THE JUNGLE JUMPAROO
IS THE SAFER WAY TO BOUNCE.
WITH STRONG,
STURDY POLES,
KIDS GET THE SENSE OF FLYING IN
THE AIR WITHOUT LOSING CONTROL.
Steve:
IT'S A JUMP/SWING/CLIMB TOY.
IT'S PERFECT FOR ALL 365 DAYS
OUT OF THE YEAR,
ALL SEASONS,
INSIDE OR OUTSIDE YOUR HOME,
AND IT COMES
IN TWO SIZES.
WHO WANTS TO JUMP ON BOARD
THIS TOTALLY TUBULAR OPPORTUNITY
WITH US?
HOW DID YOU
COME UP WITH THIS?
Rachel: A FARMER 30 YEARS AGO
MADE ONE FOR HIS GRANDKIDS,
AND HE SOLD A FEW TO, YOU KNOW,
PRESCHOOLS AND LOCAL PLACES.
SO MY PARENTS
ACTUALLY BOUGHT ONE.
I GREW UP
JUMPING ON THE ORIGINAL.
THEN YEARS PASSED BY.
ALL OF US KIDS WANTED ONE
NOW THAT WE HAVE FAMILIES.
WE CONTACTED THE FARMER,
AND, SADLY, HE HAD PASSED AWAY.
WE ENDED UP MANUFACTURING IT
FROM THAT POINT FORWARD.
AND YOU OWN
THE RIGHTS TO IT?
YES.
WE OWN THE FULL RIGHTS.
SO YOU HAVE A PATENT
ON THE BOUNCY, ROUND THING?
WE HAVE A PROVISIONAL
THAT'S FILED.
WE HAVE A UTILITY AND DESIGN
THAT ARE ALSO PENDING.
AND HOW MUCH OF YOUR OWN MONEY'S
IN THIS?
Rachel:
WE HAVE PUT $144,000 CASH --
WE HAVE NO DEBT...
WOW.
GOOD FOR YOU.
...OF OUR OWN
PERSONAL MONEY.
GOOD FOR YOU.
BUT WE HAVE TAKEN
A $70,000 SALARY.
IS THIS
YOUR FULL-TIME JOBS?
Rachel: FULL TIME.
THIS IS ALL WE DO.
WE ACTUALLY MOVED.
WE DRINK, SLEEP,
AND EAT THE JUMPAROO.
WE MOVED FOR OUR BUSINESS.
IT'S ALL WE DO.
O'Leary:
I THINK IT LOOKS DANGEROUS.
I CAN TELL YOU THIS --
WE HAD A TRAMPOLINE GROWING UP.
WE HAD A JUMPAROO,
AND WE HAD KIDS
COMING OVER CONSTANTLY
BECAUSE OF THESE TWO ITEMS.
WE HAD PLENTY OF ACCIDENTS
ON THE TRAMPOLINE.
EVERY YEAR,
105,000 KIDS GO TO THE E.R.
DUE TO TRAMPOLINE INJURIES.
TRUE.
AND WHAT'S THE RECORD
ON JUMPAROOS?
NO ONE IN 30 YEARS
EVER GOT HURT ON IT.
IT'S -- IT'S A --
WELL, THEN THAT JUST MEANS
YOU HAVEN'T SOLD ENOUGH.
HOW WOULD YOU KNOW?
HOW MANY HAVE YOU SOLD?
[ LAUGHS ]
OKAY. SO, WE'VE BEEN IN BUSINESS
FOR THE PAST 12 MONTHS,
AND WE HAVE SOLD
1,200 UNITS.
OKAY.
OUT OF THOSE 1,200 UNITS,
WE HAVE NOT HAD ONE CLAIM.
WHAT WAS THE PRICE
YOU SOLD THEM AT?
THE BIG ONE RETAILS FOR $399
ON OUR WEBSITE,
AND THE SMALL ONE
RETAILS FOR $249.
ARE YOU SELLING
IN RETAILERS?
RIGHT NOW, WE TRAVEL AROUND
DIFFERENT SAM'S CLUB LOCATIONS.
WE'RE THERE FOR A CERTAIN PERIOD
OF TIME, USUALLY 11 DAYS --
YOU'RE DOING A ROAD SHOW.
Rachel: YES.
WE'RE DOING THE ROAD SHOW
WITH SAM'S CLUB.
SO, STEVE, 1,200 UNITS
YOU'VE SOLD IN 12 MONTHS.
CORRECT.
HOW MANY OF THOSE
WERE THROUGH SAM'S CLUB,
AND HOW MANY DID YOU SELL
OTHER WAYS?
Steve: GREAT QUESTION.
WE'VE SOLD 60 TOTAL
THROUGH SAM'S CLUB.
WE WERE --
Herjavec: 60 UNITS?
60. WE WERE IN THERE
FOR THREE WEEKS,
AND WE SOLD OUT
OF PRODUCT.
OKAY.
ONE QUESTION I HAVE
IS ALWAYS,
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT A PRODUCT
IN A RETAIL STORE,
SIZE OF THE PRODUCT.
IT'S ALWAYS A PROBLEM, BECAUSE
IF THEY COULD SELL 50 THINGS
IN THAT ONE SPACE
INSTEAD OF ONE THING,
THEY'RE GONNA GO
WITH THE 50.
Steve: YEAH.
IS THIS K.D.-ABLE --
WHICH MEANS KNOCKED DOWN --
SO THAT YOUR BOX IS SMALL?
THE BOX IS 80 INCHES LONG,
20 INCHES WIDE,
AND 5 INCHES THICK,
AND SO --
SO THEY DON'T BREAK DOWN,
THOSE POLES?
THEY DON'T --
THE POLES DO NOT BREAK DOWN
CURRENTLY.
SO...
THAT -- THAT'S ACTUALLY
A PRETTY BIG CHALLENGE.
IT IS.
BECAUSE LET'S SAY
YOU WANT TO PUT IN 20 UNITS.
YOU'RE GONNA REQUIRE
A FAIR AMOUNT OF SPACE HERE.
WE -- WE HAVE -- WE --
NOW, SOME OF THOSE CAN STORE
IN BACK IN THE WAREHOUSE...
THEY CAN.
...WHICH IS WHAT
THEY'RE PROBABLY DOING.
BUT TO BE IN TOYS "R" US?
I'M MORE WORRIED ABOUT
THE DISPLAY ON THE FLOOR.
Herjavec: I LOVE TOYS.
MY WIFE SAYS I'M THE OLDEST
16-YEAR-OLD SHE KNOWS.
IF I CAN PLAY WITH IT, MY KIDS
CAN PLAY WITH IT, I'LL BUY IT.
GOT TO BE HONEST,
IT DOESN'T EXCITE ME.
I'M NOT SAYING
IT'S A BAD PRODUCT.
I JUST THINK MY KIDS
WOULD GET BORED WITH IT.
'CAUSE WE HAVE A TRAMPOLINE.
WE'VE USED IT FOR 10 YEARS.
Rachel: THIS IS NOT
A 15-MINUTE TOY.
IF YOU PUT --
THIS IS A FOUR-HOUR TOY.
PARENTS HAVE THE SAME EXPRESSION
YOU JUST DID
WHERE THEY LOOK AT IT
AND THEY GO...
"WHAT A DUMB IDEA."
..."I DON'T KNOW WHAT THIS IS."
AND THEN THEY SEE THEIR KIDS
AND GO, "I GET IT."
I DIDN'T WANT TO SAY,
"DUMB IDEA."
WE'VE HEARD IT ALL.
AND GUESS WHAT.
WE HAVE NOT HAD ONE PERSON
RETURN IT.
John:
YOU SOUND LIKE YOU'RE DOING --
YOU KNOW, YOU'RE CHUGGING ALONG.
YOU'RE FIGURING IT OUT, RIGHT?
MM-HMM.
WHY DO YOU FEEL
YOU NEED PARTNERS?
OKAY.
WE SUBMITTED TO 100 STORES.
WE JUST MET WITH SAM'S CLUB.
WE SAT DOWN WITH THE BUYER.
HE'S VERY EXCITED
ABOUT EVERYTHING.
BUT HE ASKED US...
YEAH.
SO, WE WILL --
...TO PURCHASE 11,000 UNITS.
THAT'S WHY WE NEED
THE SHARKS.
FLAT-OUT.
BECAUSE WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT --
IF WE DO WHAT WE DID IN THE
FIRST COUPLE LOCATIONS AT SAM'S,
IF WE DO SOMETHING
SIMILAR TO THAT,
THAT'S AROUND FOUR JUMPAROOS
A DAY IN 100 LOCATIONS.
THAT IS A $1.3 MILLION
PURCHASE ORDER.
SO, RIGHT NOW YOU NEED MONEY
SO YOU CAN MANUFACTURE MORE.
WHEN I FIRST STARTED, I HAD
A LITTLE EARRING ORGANIZER,
AND JCPenney SAID TO ME,
"LORI, IF YOU CAN GET
THE CHICAGOLAND AREA TO BUY,
THEN WE'LL TAKE YOU
NATIONWIDE."
SO EVERY WEEKEND,
I WENT TO A DIFFERENT JCPenney
AND I STOOD THERE ALL DAY
DEMONSTRATING
THE SLIDING EARRING STANDS
AND SHOWING MY PRODUCT
AND PULLING PEOPLE OVER.
AND IT WAS A 12-HOUR DAY
EACH DAY.
AND I SOLD ENOUGH
AND I GOT IN.
SO THERE'S TWO OF YOU.
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO GO IN,
DEMONSTRATE --
BRING KIDS,
JUMP UP AND DOWN.
HOW ARE YOU GONNA
GET 100 OF YOU?
FOR ME RIGHT NOW, I'M OUT.
THERE'S YOUR CHALLENGE,
RIGHT?
SO, A-AS -- AS A SELF-CONTAINED,
FROM-HOME BUSINESS,
THIS IS GREAT.
NOW YOU WANT TO TAKE
THAT BIG STAIR STEP.
BUT MONEY
ISN'T YOUR ONLY ISSUE,
BECAUSE ONCE
YOU'RE IN 100 STORES,
THE AGGRAVATION FACTOR
GOES THROUGH THE ROOF.
AND YOU WILL GET TO THE POINT
WHERE SOMEBODY GETS HURT.
IT'S JUST INEVITABLE.
THERE'S IDIOTS EVERYWHERE,
AND YOU CAN'T PROTECT
AGAINST SOMEONE SPRAINING
THEIR ANKLE, BREAKING AN ANKLE.
IF I'D PARTNER WITH YOU,
EVERY TIME WE SOLD ONE,
I'D HAVE TO CROSS MY FINGERS
AND CROSS MY TOES
THAT IT WASN'T MY KIDS
THAT BROKE THEIR ANKLE.
THAT'S JUST MY NATURE.
AND SO I-I DON'T SEE MYSELF
BEING A GOOD PARTNER FOR YOU,
SO I'M OUT.
THIS IS A KID MAGNET.
I DON'T THINK ANY ADULT
CAN UNDERSTAND HOW FUN IT IS
UNTIL YOU SEE YOUR KIDS
JUMPING ON IT.
AND IT IS SAFER THAN A TRAMPO--
Herjavec:
IT -- YEAH, LISTEN TO ME.
I HAVE AN IMMENSE AMOUNT
OF RESPECT
OF PEOPLE THAT TAKE AN IDEA
AND CREATE A COMPANY OUT OF IT.
BUT I GOT TO REALLY
BELIEVE IN THE PRODUCT.
I DON'T SEE THIS
TAKING OVER THE TRAMPOLINE
OR BEING A SUPPLEMENT
TO THAT BUSINESS.
SO IT JUST --
IT DOESN'T EXCITE ME THAT WAY.
I'M OUT.
WHAT EXCITES ME
IS MAKING MONEY.
YOU KNOW, I DON'T CARE
IF THEY'RE BOUNCING UPSIDE DOWN
OR WHATEVER OR HANGING
LIKE A PRISONER IN A CAGE
AS LONG AS
YOU'RE MAKING MONEY.
[ LAUGHS ]
THAT'S ALL I CARE ABOUT.
BUT TO REALLY SCALE THIS PUPPY,
YOU'VE GOT SOME BIG CHALLENGES
BECAUSE OF THE FLOOR SPACE,
THE FOOTPRINT OF THE PRODUCT.
I THINK THAT'LL ALWAYS LIMIT
HOW MUCH YOU CAN SELL
IN ANY ONE SEASON.
I'M OUT.
OKAY.
I THINK THIS TRULY
WILL TAKE A PORTION
OF THE TRAMPOLINE MARKET.
I'M GOING TO HIT A HOME RUN
WITH THIS.
AND I AM A FIGHTER
AND I'M NOT GONNA GIVE UP.
John: SO, RACHEL, STEVE,
I HAVE ONE QUICK QUESTION.
YOU'RE MAKING IT FOR HOW MUCH,
AND HOW MUCH
ARE YOU SELLING IT FOR?
WE MANUFACTURE IT FOR $125
FOR THE LARGE ONE...
OKAY.
...AND WE'RE CUR--
AND THEN YOU'RE SELLING IT
TO SAM'S CLUB...
FOR $278.
IF YOU JUST LOOK AT THE
100 STORES YOU'RE GOING INTO,
THE MARGIN
IS GONNA KILL YOU.
YOU CAME UP WITH A GREAT IDEA
OF A LOCAL PRODUCT.
YOU KNOW, WHERE I CAME FROM,
WHEN WE DIDN'T HAVE A POOL,
WE JUST FILLED UP
TWO GARBAGE PAILS
AND PLAYED "MARCO POLO" IN THAT,
RIGHT?
SO, I HAVE TO COMMEND YOU
ON THAT.
[ LAUGHS ]
BUT OTHER THAN THAT,
THE FINANCES DON'T WORK IN THIS
FOR YOU TO HAVE A PARTNER.
SO I'M OUT.
OKAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
Herjavec: THANK YOU.
APPRECIATE IT.
GOOD LUCK, GUYS.
John: GOOD LUCK.
THANK YOU.
CONGRATS.
[ SNAPS FINGERS ]
[ CHUCKLES ]
[ GROANS ]
Steve: I'M DISAPPOINTED.
I'M FRUSTRATED
THAT THEY DIDN'T UNDERSTAND IT.
I REALLY FELT LIKE
THIS WAS OUR BIG OPPORTUNITY
AND OUR BIG CHANCE TO REALLY
TAKE IT TO THAT NEXT LEVEL
LIKE DAYMOND TALKED ABOUT.
AND IT'S FRUSTRATING
TO HIT A WALL.
I'M MEGHAN TARMEY.
I'M FROM MYRTLE BEACH,
SOUTH CAROLINA.
NICE SHOT.
MY COMPANY IS CALLED
THE CADDY GIRLS.
IT'S THE FIRST ALL-FEMALE
GOLF-CADDYING COMPANY.
WE PROVIDE THE REFRESHING
COMPANY OF A BEAUTIFUL WOMAN
THAT IS ALSO A GREAT CADDY.
WE DRIVE THE CART,
KEEP THE SCORE,
TEND THE PIN, RAKE SAND TRAPS,
READ THE GREENS.
AND ON TOP OF THAT,
WE'RE YOUR PERSONAL CHEERLEADERS
TO DO BACKFLIPS
FOR WHEN YOU GET BIRDIES.
YES!
THERE WE GO!
I CAME UP WITH MY BUSINESS
BACK WHEN I WAS IN COLLEGE.
I LEARNED EVERYTHING
THERE IS TO KNOW ABOUT GOLF
AND I STARTED CADDYING
AT ALL THE LOCAL COURSES.
THE CONCEPT
WAS AN IMMEDIATE HIT,
AND NOW I HAVE A STAFF
OF OVER 70 GIRLS,
AND WE WORK EVENTS AND
TOURNAMENTS FROM COAST TO COAST.
THE GIRLS WILL BE THERE
20 MINUTES BEFORE YOUR TEE TIME.
I AM COMPLETELY IMMERSED
IN HUSTLING EVERY SINGLE DAY
TO GET THIS COMPANY
OFF THE GROUND.
BUT THE MONEY THAT I'M MAKING
OFF OF MY COMPANY RIGHT NOW
IS NOT ENOUGH TO LIVE OFF OF
AND EXPAND MY BUSINESS.
I NEED AN INVESTMENT
FROM THE SHARKS
TO TAKE THE MODEL THAT I HAVE
HERE IN MYRTLE BEACH
TO EVERY OTHER MAJOR GOLF MARKET
IN AMERICA.
WITH THE RIGHT SHARK,
I KNOW THAT MY BUSINESS
COULD BE A HOLE IN ONE.
HELLO, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS MEGHAN TARMEY.
I'M FROM MYRTLE BEACH,
SOUTH CAROLINA,
AND MY COMPANY IS...
THE CADDY GIRLS.
I'M SEEKING $100,000 IN EXCHANGE
FOR 20% OF MY COMPANY.
SO, THE CADDY GIRLS
IS AN ALL-FEMALE
GOLF-CADDYING COMPANY.
WE STAFF EVERYTHING
FROM EVERYDAY GOLF OUTINGS
TO HUGE CORPORATE
CHARITY TOURNAMENTS
WITH MY AMAZING,
GOLF-KNOWLEDGEABLE,
AND ATTRACTIVE CADDIES.
WE TRY TO EMPHASIZE
THE FUN FACTOR OF GOLF,
BUT WE ALSO MAINTAIN
A VERY PROFESSIONAL ATTITUDE
ABOUT GOLF.
SHARKS, MY COMPANY
IS A HOLE IN ONE.
SO WHICH ONE OF YOU
IS GONNA HELP ME...
DRIVE MY COMPANY
TO THE GREEN?
I'M CURIOUS.
WHERE DO YOU DO THIS?
WE'RE BASED OUT OF
MYRTLE BEACH, SOUTH CAROLINA,
BUT WE'VE ACTUALLY
BEEN EXPANDING
TO OTHER MAJOR GOLF MARKETS,
SUCH AS SCOTTSDALE.
WE EVEN HAVE CADDY GIRLS NOW
IN LOS ANGELES, MIAMI, ORLANDO,
AND PARTS OF GEORGIA.
MEGHAN, HOW BIG
IS YOUR BUSINESS?
WHAT ARE YOUR REVENUES?
IN 2013,
I HAD $148,000 IN SALES.
GOOD FOR YOU.
GOOD.
O'Leary: THAT'S NOT BAD.
WE DID $34,000
IN SALES LAST MONTH.
WHAT'S THE MAIN BULK
OF YOUR BUSINESS?
IT COULD BE AN EVERYDAY
GOLF OUTING WITH FOUR GUYS.
IT COULD BE A HUGE GOLF OUTING
WITH 144 PLAYERS
IN A TOURNAMENT.
WE'VE HAD
HUGE CORPORATE CLIENTS
ACTUALLY HIRE UP TO 42 CADDIES
IN ONE DAY.
O'Leary:
GIVE US THE NUMBERS.
I CALL YOU UP.
I'VE GOT A CORPORATE EVENT.
AND I WANT TO HIRE CADDIES
FOR EVERYBODY.
THE LOWEST RATE THAT WE HAVE FOR
EACH CADDY IS $149 PER CADDY.
WELL, YOU GET $149.
NOW, WHAT DO YOU PAY THEM?
I PAY EVERY CADDY $100.
Greiner: IS THAT FOR 9 HOLES?
18 HOLES?
18 HOLES.
9 HOLES IS $89.
MEGHAN, HOW'D YOU COME UP
WITH THE IDEA?
I WAS, HONESTLY, IN COLLEGE
AND COMPLETELY BROKE.
I WAS BARTENDING
IN MYRTLE BEACH,
WHERE THERE'S
A HUNDRED GOLF COURSES,
AND I NOTICED
THAT I REALLY LIKED GOLFERS.
THEY TIPPED THE BEST, AND ONE
GROUP CAME UP TO ME ONE NIGHT,
AND THEY'RE LIKE, "HEY,
WE WANT YOU TO COME
GOLF WITH US TOMORROW.
WE'LL PAY YOU."
AND I'M LIKE, "THAT'S WEIRD."
[ LAUGHTER ]
BUT HERE'S THE THING --
A LIGHT BULB WENT OF,
AND I WAS LIKE,
"YOU KNOW, IT WOULD BE
REALLY AWESOME IF I
MAKE MY OWN SCHEDULE.
"I WANT TO BE
OUT ON THE GOLF COURSE
AND TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THIS MARKET."
MEGHAN, TAKE THIS QUESTION
THE ABSOLUTE MOST INNOCENT WAY.
MOST GUYS ARE PIGS.
SPEAK FOR YOURSELF,
COCHON.
WHEN THEY'RE HIRING
THE BEAUTIFUL LADIES --
I DON'T MEAN THIS
IN A DISRESPECTFUL WAY --
ARE THEY HIRING THEM FOR GOLF,
OR IS IT JUST A FUN THING?
WE ARE NOT PEOPLE TO COME
AND GET HIRED TO HANG OUT
WITH GUYS, OKAY?
LIKE, OUR WHOLE NICHE
IS THAT WE ARE HOT GIRLS
THAT KNOW ABOUT GOLF.
DO YOU DO TRADITIONAL
CADDY THINGS?
YES. WE'RE GETTING YOUR CLUBS
TO AND FROM YOU.
WE'RE FIXING PITCH MARKS.
WE'RE RAKING EVERY SAND TRAP.
WE'RE TENDING THE PIN.
WE'RE HELPING YOU
GET YOUR YARDAGE.
EVERYTHING THAT A CADDY
WOULD NORMALLY DO, WE DO THAT.
WE JUST HAD FOUR OF OUR GIRLS
CONTRACTED
FOR THE PGA-SANCTIONED
NATIONAL CHAMPIONSHIP
COMING UP IN TWO WEEKS.
THAT'S GONNA BE TELEVISED.
FOUR OF MY GIRLS
ARE CARRYING BAGS.
HOW DO YOU MAKE THIS MORE THAN
A REGIONALLY BASED BUSINESS?
A STANDARD GOLF TOURNAMENT
HAS 144 PLAYERS.
THAT'S 144 PEOPLE THAT GO HOME
AND TELL THEIR GOLF BUDDIES
ABOUT IT,
AND THEN IT'S JUST --
IT SPREADS.
HALF OF OUR BUSINESS THIS YEAR
WAS REPEAT BUSINESS.
AND BIG CORPORATE TOURNAMENTS,
WE ALREADY HAVE SOME LINED UP
THROUGH DECEMBER.
AND THIS IS NOT JUST, LIKE,
ONE OR TWO GIRLS GOING OUT.
THIS IS 30 TO 40 GIRLS
GOING OUT, YOU KNOW, IN ONE DAY.
$100,000 FOR 20%.
YOU THINK THIS IS WORTH
HALF A MILLION BUCKS?
YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT
THE LIFETIME CUSTOMER VALUE.
GOLF ISN'T GOING ANYWHERE.
THE USE OF ATTRACTIVE PEOPLE
ISN'T GOING ANYWHERE.
AND WE HAVE A DATABASE
OF THOUSANDS OF CUSTOMERS
THAT HAVE USED US
IN THE PAST.
EVERYTHING'S GREAT.
I HAVE 70 GIRLS WORKING,
BOOKINGS EVERY DAY.
I WANT TO TAKE THAT
AND EXPAND THAT TO OTHER PLACES.
BUT WE ALSO HAVE PEOPLE
ASKING FOR CADDIES
IN CHICAGO, MINNEAPOLIS --
ALL THESE AREAS
THAT I WOULD LOVE TO GET INTO.
Greiner:
YOU KNOW, FOR ME, I JUST SEE
SO MANY ISSUES OR PROBLEMS
THAT I COULD FORESEE HAPPENING
WITH THIS.
IT WORRIES ME SOMETIMES,
JUST FOR YOU GUYS, PERIOD,
TO BE OUT THERE WITH
THE DRINKING AND THIS AND THAT.
I -- IT'S JUST NOT A BUSINESS
I COULD GET BEHIND.
SO FOR THAT REASON,
I'M OUT.
I UNDERSTAND.
AND THAT'S WHY WE HAVE VERY,
VERY STRICT STANDARDS OF CONDUCT
FOR ALL OF OUR CADDIES.
AND I THINK WITH ANY JOB PLACE,
YOU HAVE A LIABILITY
FOR ANY KIND OF HARASSMENT
OR ANYTHING THAT CAN GO ON.
IT CAN HAPPEN ANYWHERE.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
MEGHAN, LET ME --
LET ME JUMP IN HERE.
I THINK YOU CAN TURN THIS
INTO SOMETHING SPECIAL.
BUT I HATE GOLF,
SO I'M OUT.
[ LAUGHS ]
WE COULD MAKE YOU LIKE GOLF
A LITTLE BIT MORE.
MAYBE IF YOU HAD A CADDY GIRL
WITH YOU, YOU'D LIKE IT.
THIS IS SUPER FUN.
Cuban: I CAN THINK OF
A HUNDRED THOUSAND THINGS
I WOULD RATHER DO THAN
SCHLEP AROUND A GOLF COURSE.
John: YOU KNOW, JUST LIKE MARK,
I-I DON'T LIKE GOLF.
BUT I-I LIKE THE CONCEPT.
I THINK YOU'RE IN
A TOUGH POSITION,
BECAUSE, FIRST OF ALL,
YOU DO NEED TO EXPAND
BECAUSE SOMEBODY ELSE WILL TRY
TO COME UP WITH THE IDEA
AND BE YOUR COMPETITION.
BUT ON THE OTHER HAND,
YOU SPREAD YOURSELF TOO THIN...
YOU'RE NOT GONNA MAKE
ENOUGH MONEY IN EACH MARKET.
I THINK THERE'S
TOO MUCH WORK HERE.
SO I'D HAVE TO BE OUT.
THANK YOU.
Herjavec: SO, I-I THINK
YOU'VE GOT A GREAT BUSINESS.
YOU'VE BUILT IT
FROM NOTHING.
BUT EVERY BUSINESS IS A LIVING,
BREATHING THING,
AND IT GOES THROUGH
DIFFERENT STAGES.
THERE'S THE HUSTLE STAGE,
WHERE YOU NEED MORE HUSTLE,
MORE TIME,
AND YOU JUST GOT TO FIND MORE
HOURS THAN THE 24 YOU'RE GIVEN.
AND THEN SOME BUSINESSES
GET TO THE INVESTMENT STAGE.
YOU'RE IN THE HUSTLE STAGE.
I DON'T --
YOU DIDN'T
DO A GOOD JOB TODAY
OF TELLING ME HOW,
AS AN INVESTOR,
I GIVE YOU $100,000 AND YOU
MAKE THE BUSINESS GO BOOM.
YOU GOT LOTS OF HUSTLE.
I WAS --
SO KEEP GOING.
BUT I'M OUT.
ALL RIGHT.
WHO'S LEFT?
IT'S JUST YOU,
THE WORST GOLFER IN THE WORLD.
MR. WONDERFUL.
HE'S OUR IDEAL CUSTOMER.
HE'S PERFECT. SHOWS UP GRUMPY.
ALL OF A SUDDEN, HE HAS A CADDY,
AND HE'S SUPER HAPPY.
[ LAUGHTER ]
BUT, MEGHAN,
HE'S GRUMPY ALL THE TIME.
I ACTUALLY --
I'M VERY IMPRESSED WITH YOU
BECAUSE I THOUGHT
THIS PRESENTATION
WAS GOING TO BE
JUST RIDICULOUS.
AND YOU COME BACK...
DID A GOOD JOB.
...AND DID A PRETTY GOOD JOB.
YEAH.
YOU DID.
SO GOOD FOR YOU.
BUT, YOU KNOW,
IS IT INVESTABLE?
I GIVE YOU $100,000, I DON'T
KNOW HOW I EVER GET IT BACK.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
AT OUR GROWTH RATE OF 30%
EVERY YEAR AS AN AVERAGE,
YOU WOULD GET IT BACK
WITHIN FOUR YEARS EASILY.
THE ONLY THING THAT MATTERS
IN BUSINESS IS CASH.
WHEN IT LEAVES -- AND RIGHT NOW
IT'S AROUND MY ANKLE GOING,
"DADDY, NO! DADDY, NO!" --
AND I GIVE IT TO YOU...
Greiner: [ LAUGHS ]
...NOW IT'S REALLY SCARED
'CAUSE IT DOESN'T KNOW
WHEN IT'S COMING HOME.
I WOULD -- I WOULD IDEALLY
LIKE TO PAY YOU BACK
BY THE END OF THE YEAR
AND THEN HAVE YOU AS A PARTNER.
I'VE NEVER MARKETED THIS.
IF WE HAD A BOOTH AT THE PGA
SHOW IN ORLANDO EVERY YEAR,
FORGET IT -- OUR BOOKINGS
WOULD BE THROUGH THE ROOF.
ALL RIGHT.
I'VE HEARD ENOUGH.
I'M GONNA
MAKE YOU AN OFFER.
THE ONLY WAY THIS WORKS
IS VERY SIMPLE.
I GIVE YOU $100,000.
I BECOME A 50/50 PARTNER.
AND THE REASON YOU WOULD DO THIS
IS ONLY IF YOU BELIEVED
YOU COULD MORE THAN DOUBLE
YOUR BUSINESS WITH MY $100,000.
I CAN GUARANTEE YOU
THE DEVIL
WOULD GIVE YOU A BETTER DEAL
THAN KEVIN.
NEGOTIATE A LITTLE BIT AND IT'S
NOT THAT BAD A DEAL, RIGHT?
BECAUSE YOU --
IT'S A HORRIBLE DEAL.
IT'S NOT THAT BAD A DEAL.
50% FOR $100,000.
YOU KNOW,
ISN'T TALK CHEAP, MEGHAN?
THE ONLY SHARK THAT BELIEVED
IN YOU IS MR. WONDERFUL.
THAT'S IT.
WHICH IS...REALLY SURPRISING.
[ LAUGHTER ]
BUT...
GOOD ANSWER.
IF YOU REALLY DON'T THINK
YOU CAN MORE THAN DOUBLE IT,
DON'T DO THIS DEAL.
I KNOW I COULD.
THEN WHAT
ARE YOU WORRIED ABOUT?
I JUST DON'T WANT
TO GIVE YOU HALF.
WOULD YOU CONSIDER 40%?
NEVER.
DAMN IT.
MEGHAN, YOU GOT TO
MAKE A DECISION.
I JUST THINK, AT THIS TIME,
50% IS TOO -- TOO MUCH
FOR WHAT I'VE PUT INTO IT.
ARE YOU OFFICIALLY
DECLINING HIS OFFER?
YES.
THEN I'M OUT.
THANK YOU.
I APPRECIATE IT A LOT.
MEGHAN, YOU DID A GREAT JOB.
Greiner: GOOD LUCK, MEGHAN.
THANK YOU GUYS.
THANK YOU, LADIES.
SEE YOU GUYS.
YOU DID A GOOD JOB.
I'M NOT GIVING HIM
HALF OF WHAT I HAVE.
NO.
NO, THAT'S RIDICULOUS.
HE WAS JUST
PUTTING SOMETHING --
THAT'S LIKE A DIVORCE.
YEAH.
[ ALL CHUCKLE ]
I KNOW MY WORTH
AND I KNOW MY COMPANY'S WORTH,
AND WHAT KEVIN WAS OFFERING ME
JUST WASN'T WORTH IT TO ME.
Narrator:
NEXT UP ARE ENTREPRENEURS
WITH A MODERN AND AFFORDABLE WAY
TO BE FASHIONABLE.
HI, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS JOSH HARBOUR.
AND I'M DIANA HARBOUR.
AND WE ARE FROM ATHENS, GEORGIA.
OUR COMPANY
IS THE RED DRESS BOUTIQUE.
WE ARE SEEKING $600,000
IN EXCHANGE FOR 5% EQUITY
IN OUR COMPANY.
THE RED DRESS BOUTIQUE
IS ONE OF THE FASTEST-GROWING
ONLINE WOMEN'S RETAILERS
IN THE COUNTRY.
WE HAVE A PERSONAL TOUCH
THAT NO ONE ELSE CAN BEAT.
I AM ALWAYS FINDING NEW
AND UPCOMING DESIGNERS,
AND WE [CHUCKLES]
UPDATE OUR COLLECTIONS DAILY.
WE CATER TO THE WOMAN THAT WANTS
TO LOOK LIKE A MILLION BUCKS.
BUT SHE DOESN'T HAVE TO HAVE
A MILLION BUCKS.
ROUGHLY 80% OF OUR MERCHANDISE
RETAILS FOR UNDER $50.
SOMETIMES ALL A WOMAN NEEDS
IS THAT ONE FANTASTIC NEW OUTFIT
TO TURN A BAD DAY
INTO A GOOD ONE,
TO GIVE A WOMAN
THE CONFIDENCE SHE NEEDS
GOING INTO AN INTERVIEW
OR TO GIVE THAT STAY-AT-HOME MOM
A REASON TO SMILE
AFTER THAT RARE MOMENT
SHE TREATS HERSELF.
AND WE HAVE SOME TREATS
FOR YOU.
Cuban: YAY.
GOOD.
Herjavec: WE LIKE TREATS.
Diana: WE FIGURED YOU WOULD.
I LOVE THAT DRESS.
THAT DRESS IS BEAUTIFUL.
THANK YOU.
HOW MUCH DOES THAT COST?
$52.
WHAT?
YES.
John: WOW.
AND ABBY'S DRESS IS $40.
Greiner: I WANT IT.
Herjavec:
THANK YOU.
NOW, THIS IS HOW WE PACKAGE
EVERY SINGLE ORDER
THAT GOES OUT TO OUR CUSTOMERS
AT RED DRESS.
IT IS LITERALLY A PRESENT
TO THE CUSTOMERS.
WE PUT A HANDWRITTEN
THANK-YOU NOTE IN EVERY ORDER.
THANK YOU.
[ THUD ]
OH, MY. JEWELRY FELL OUT.
JEWELRY IS IN THERE, TOO,
MATCHED TO YOUR OUTFIT.
BASICALLY, THAT IS WHAT
A RED DRESS WOMAN SHOPS FOR.
IF SHE'S COMING TO THE SITE,
SHE HAS LITTLE TO NO TIME
TO SHOP FOR HERSELF.
WE PAIR IT AND MATCH IT
AS AN OUTFIT.
BUT YOU'RE RECOMMENDING THESE
COLLECTED TOGETHER.
RIGHT. AND THAT'S ACTUALLY
HOW THE CUSTOMER --
SO YOU'RE CURATING THE LOOK
OF THIS PERSON.
I AM CURATING THE LOOK.
IF I WAS TO SELECT THIS,
WOULD IT AUTOMATICALLY SUGGEST
THAT I BUY THE REST OF THIS?
IT WOULD.
DIANA, WHAT IS THE AVERAGE BUY
FROM A WOMAN ONLINE?
$75 PER ORDER.
PER -- PER PURCHASE?
PER PURCHASE.
AND HOW OFTEN
DO THEY RE-ORDER
THROUGHOUT
A 12-MONTH PERIOD?
WE HAVE A LOT
OF RETURN CUSTOMERS
THAT ORDER, ON AVERAGE,
ABOUT SIX OR SEVEN TIMES A YEAR.
WE ALSO HAVE -- WE'RE GETTING
NEW CUSTOMERS ALL THE TIME.
WHAT ARE YOUR SALES
LAST YEAR?
$8 MILLION
IN GROSS SALES.
Cuban: GOOD FOR YOU.
AND WE'RE ON TARGET
TO DO $12 MILLION
TO $15 MILLION THIS YEAR.
WOW.
HOW LONG YOU BEEN IN BUSINESS?
THE WEBSITE'S ONLY 4.
FOUR YEARS?
4 YEARS OLD.
WOW.
WHAT ARE THE SALES
THE FIRST YEAR?
2010, VERY MODEST,
$80,000.
2011, $250,000.
2012, $1.8 MILLION.
WHAT WAS 113?
113 WAS $7.5 MILLION.
WHAT WILL SALES BE
THIS YEAR?
PROJECTING $12 MILLION
TO $15 MILLION.
WELL, WE'RE DOING
$1 MILLION A MONTH.
I'M REALLY PROUD
OF RED DRESS.
CONGRATULATIONS.
IT'S A REALLY FUN STORY,
BECAUSE WE WERE MARRIED
FOR SIX MONTHS.
AND GRO--
WE'RE FRESH OUT OF COLLEGE
AND WE WERE WORKING
CUBICLE JOBS
AT A CREDIT-CARD-PROCESSING
COMPANY.
AND I CAME UP WITH THE RED DRESS
IN THE CUBICLE,
AND I WENT TO JOSH
AND I SAID,
"I HAVE THIS GREAT IDEA
FOR A BOUTIQUE
AND I KNOW I CAN DO THIS."
SO WE BOTH ENDED UP QUITTING
OUR CUBICLE JOBS, AGE 24,
SOLD OUR HOUSE,
TOOK OUT A SIX-FIGURE LOAN
WE HAD NO IDEA
IF WE COULD EVER REPAY.
AND WE RENTED AN AIR MATTRESS
AND SHACKED UP
WITH RA-- JOSH'S COLLEGE BUDDIES
FOR AN ENTIRE YEAR.
HOW DID YOU MAKE THIS GROW
SO BIG SO FAST AND ALL ONLINE?
THROUGH SOCIAL MEDIA.
BUT MORE THAN THAT,
IT'S BECAUSE I INVITE PEOPLE IN.
I PUT THE QUESTION
TO MY CUSTOMERS --
I WAS LIKE,
"WHAT MADE Y'ALL COME TO ME?
WHAT MAKES US --
WHAT MAKES RED DRESS SPECIAL?"
AND THEY GAVE
AMAZING ANSWERS
AND SAID, "OH,
IT'S THE COLORFUL CLOTHES."
"IT'S THE FACT THAT WE CAN GET
A HIGH-END LOOK FOR UNDER $50."
"IT'S --"
SO, YOU LEARNED FROM THEM.
YES.
YOU USED SOCIAL MEDIA...
I DID.
...AND YOU KEPT PERFECTING YOUR
BUSINESS WITH THEIR ANSWERS.
I DID. I DEVELOPED A PROGRAM
CALLED BUY FOR THE BOUTIQUE.
AND WHEN I GO TO MY MARKETS --
I GO EVERY THREE WEEKS.
I GO TO LOS ANGELES,
I GO TO VEGAS,
I GO TO ATLANTA,
AND I CURATE.
BUT MORE THAN THAT,
I SEE ITEMS,
AND I WILL TAKE A PICTURE OF IT
WITH MY PHONE,
AND I WILL THROW IT OUT
INTO SOCIAL MEDIA AND SAY,
"DO YOU LOVE THIS?
YES OR NO?
"DO YOU WANT IT IN RED?
OHH.
"DO YOU WANT IT IN BLUE?"
VERY, VERY CLEVER.
OKAY.
AND NO ONE HAD EVER DONE THAT
BEFORE, AND THEY LOVED IT.
IT WAS ALL WORD OF MOUTH
GAVE YOU A 4X GROWTH?
YES.
WE HAVE 127,000
INSTAGRAM FOLLOWERS.
WE ARE JUST SHY OF A MILLION
FOLLOWERS ON FACEBOOK --
ORGANIC FOLLOWERS.
YOU WENT FROM $1.8 MILLION
TO $7.5 MILLION.
THAT'S PHENOMENAL.
DID SOMETHING HAPPEN
IN THAT TIME PERIOD?
YES.
MY DAD ACTUALLY DIED
IN OCTOBER OF 2012.
OH, I'M SORRY.
MY DAD WAS THE PERSON
WHO GOT ME STARTED ON RED DRESS
JUST BY BEING A MENTOR.
AND SO I TOOK MY GRIEF
AND I USED IT AS FUEL
TO PUSH RED DRESS AS FAR
AS I COULD GET IT TO GO.
THAT'S MY MOTIVATOR.
AND THAT'S A MOTIVATOR
THAT WOULD DIE WITH ME,
BECAUSE I LIVE EVERY DAY
TO KEEP MAKING HIM PROUD.
HE CALLED ME HIS ACORN.
Greiner: AWW.
O'Leary:
SO, ON THAT $13 MILLION,
HOW MUCH FREE CASH
ARE YOU GOING TO NET?
PROBABLY $2 MILLION
IN NET PROFIT.
WHAT DO YOU RECKON IT COSTS YOU
TO GET A NEW CUSTOMER?
WE'VE JUST NOW STARTED TO GET
INTO REALLY THOROUGH ANALYTICS,
AND IT TAKES TIME
TO ACCRUE THAT DATA.
SO YOU'VE HAD
THIS PHENOMENAL GROWTH
ON WORD OF MOUTH
AND VIRAL ASPECTS.
YES.
WHEN YOU GET TO, YOU KNOW,
$10 MILLION
AND YOU WANT TO GET
TO $20 MILLION...
MM-HMM.
...YOU'RE GONNA
START TO COMPETE
WITH SOME PRETTY HEAVY HITTERS
IN THIS SPACE.
YES, WE ARE.
THEY'RE SPENDING
A LOT OF MONEY
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
THE INCREMENTAL COST
OF EVERY NEW CUSTOMER
AND THE LIFETIME VALUE.
WE'VE JUST NOW STARTED ROLLING
OUT THE RE-TARGETING ADS.
THAT WAS SOMETHING THAT
HAS BEEN REALLY GREAT FOR US.
AND WE'RE JUST NOW GETTING BACK
THE DATA ON THAT.
I'D LIKE TO DRAW
AN ANALOGY.
THERE'S A GREAT STORY IN FASHION
AROUND VIDAL SASSOON,
WHO WAS THE FIRST TO CURATE HAIR
FOR WOMEN.
BUT WHEN THEY TRIED
TO EXPAND,
THEY FOUND OUT THAT
THEY COULDN'T CLONE HIM.
AND HE TRIED TO TRAIN PEOPLE
IN EVERY CITY TO DO THIS,
AND THEY HAD
HORRIFIC PROBLEMS.
I'M VERY WORRIED HERE.
TO ME, THE ROAD AHEAD IS --
IS ONE
WHERE YOU'RE GONNA FACE
THE SAME ISSUE SASSOON FACED.
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
CLONE YOURSELF,
AND IT'S NOT EASY TO DO.
IT'S NOT EASY TO DO,
BUT I HAVE STARTED THE PROCESS.
TO ME, THAT'S A RISK
THAT I DON'T WANT TO TAKE.
I'M OUT.
KEVIN, THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU.
I'M EXTREMELY
IMPRESSED BY YOU.
YOU CALLED YOURSELF
AN ACORN,
AND I SEE YOU'VE GROWN INTO,
LIKE, A MOUNTAIN FULL OF TREES.
YOU'RE AMAZING.
AND WHAT YOU DID
WITH SOCIAL MEDIA, TO ME,
JUST IS MIND-BOGGLING
AND INCREDIBLY IMPRESSIVE.
THANK YOU.
I ACTUALLY COULD LEARN FROM YOU
IN THE SOCIAL-MEDIA REALM
OF HOW YOU HAVE GROWN
YOUR BUSINESS.
BUT I THINK THAT I'M NOT
THE RIGHT SHARK FOR YOU
TO DRIVE THIS BUSINESS.
SO FOR THAT REASON,
I'M OUT.
YOU KNOW, THIS REMINDS ME
OF THE WAY I STARTED WITH FUBU.
I WAS JUST TALKING DIRECTLY
TO THE CUSTOMER,
AND NOBODY ELSE
KNEW HOW TO DO IT.
AND THAT'S HOW I GOT HERE.
YOU GUYS ARE THE FUBU
OF YOUR CATEGORY.
I'M -- PROBABLY LIKE LORI,
I'D BE LEARNING FROM YOU.
YOU'RE HERE
FOR A STRATEGIC PARTNER.
I WISH I COULD HELP YOU,
BUT I CAN'T.
SO I'M OUT.
WHY DO YOU NEED $600,000?
WHY ARE YOU HERE?
MARK, YOU'VE SAID
IN INTERVIEWS
THAT Y-YOU REALLY WANT
TO BE NEEDED BUT NOT NECESSARY.
THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING FOR.
WE'RE LOOKING FOR SOMEONE
WHO CAN HELP US
WALK THROUGH THE HIGH --
SOME HIGH-LEVEL DECISIONS
TO GET US TO THAT NEXT LEVEL,
BECAUSE EVERY ONE OF YOU
IS HERE RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE, AT SOME POINT,
YOU TOOK A SMALL COMPANY
AND YOU SCALED IT
TO A MASSIVE COMPANY.
WE HAVE FIGURED OUT HOW TO GROW
A COMPANY FROM NOTHING
TO OVER $1 MILLION A MONTH
IN SALES.
BUT GETTING
TO NINE FIGURES A YEAR,
IT'S A WHOLE DIFFERENT THING.
Diana: IT TAKES A MENTOR
WHO'S WALKED THE PATH BEFORE US.
AND THE $600,000, WE NEED
$300,000 OF IT FOR A NEW WEBSITE
BECAUSE WE HAVE ACTUALLY
MAXED OUT THE CAPACITY
OF THE OUT-OF-THE-BOX SYSTEM
THAT WE HAVE.
AND A BACK-END SYSTEM
FOR OUR WEBSITE.
IT REALLY IS GIVING US NOT VERY
GOOD BUSINESS DATA AT ALL.
Herjavec: THAT'S MY WORLD.
ANALYTICS,
ENTERPRISE TYPE OF INFORMATION,
THAT'S WHERE I LIVE
EVERY DAY.
TO BE HONEST,
THAT'S WHERE I'M WEAK.
WELL, THAT -- THAT'S WHERE
I'M VERY, VERY STRONG.
I THINK I CAN ADD A LOT OF VALUE
ON THE BACK END,
WHICH IS WHAT I THINK
YOU NEED RIGHT NOW.
I'LL GIVE YOU THE $600,000
FOR 15%.
FIRST OF ALL,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THAT'S A HUGE GESTURE OF FAITH
IN WHAT WE'RE DOING.
RIGHT NOW, I THINK 15%
IS A LITTLE MORE EQUITY
THAN WE WERE PLANNING ON
GIVING UP FOR THAT VALUATION.
RESPECTFULLY,
WE DO HAVE TO DECLINE THAT.
I'M GONNA STAY THERE.
THANK YOU.
I LOVE YOU GUYS, RIGHT?
I THINK WHAT YOU'RE DOING
IS GREAT.
AND IF YOU CAN COME UP
WITH A WAY TO AUTOMATE THIS
SO YOU CAN SCALE,
THEN YOU GUYS ARE GOING PUBLIC,
YOU'RE --
YOU'RE A $100 MILLION COMPANY,
AND YOU'RE --
YOU'RE CHANGING THE GAME.
Diana: YES.
WHAT DO YOU GUYS THINK
IS FAIR EQUITY?
JUST TELL ME, AND I'LL JUST
GIVE YOU A YES OR A NO.
AS FAR AS
EQUITY PERCENTAGE?
YEAH, FOR THE 600K.
Narrator:
THREE SHARKS ARE OUT.
MARK HAS ASKED DIANA AND JOSH
TO MAKE HIM A BETTER OFFER
THAN THE $600,000 FOR 5%
THEY WERE ORIGINALLY SEEKING
FOR THEIR ONLINE FASHION SHOP,
RED DRESS BOUTIQUE.
FOR $600,000...
I -- WE WOULD GO
AS HIGH AS 10%.
$600,000 FOR 10%
IS WHAT YOU WOULD GO.
Herjavec:
THIS IS MY SPACE, MAN.
Diana: ROBERT, IF --
AT THE NUMBERS WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT WITH MARK,
WOULD YOU CONSIDER
GOING IN TOGETHER?
ROBERT,
WOULD YOU COUNTER?
LOOK, IF YOU'D RATHER
HAVE ROBERT, I'M FINE.
Diana: NO.
THAT'S NOT WHAT WE'RE SAYING.
TWO SHARKS
IS ALWAYS BETTER THAN ONE.
TWO -- TWO MINDS
THAT ARE BRILLIANT.
IT'S JUST NOT -- YEAH,
IT'S JUST NOT ENOUGH EQUITY...
RIGHT. UNDERSTOOD.
...ONCE YOU GET --
YEAH. THERE'S JUST NOT ENOUGH
SKIN IN THE GAME.
WHAT ABOUT $1.2 MILLION
FOR 20%?
MARK CAN TAKE THE 10%.
I'LL TAKE THE 10%.
THAT WAY WE HAVE
THE SAME AMOUNT OF EQUITY.
I WOULD DO THAT.
THE TWO OF YOU TOGETHER?
Cuban: YEAH.
$1.2 MILLION FOR 20%.
EACH OF US WILL PUT UP 600K.
YES.
Herjavec: ALL RIGHT.
DEAL.
Greiner:
AND I WANT THAT DRESS.
[ LAUGHS ]
CONGRATULATIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YEAH, I'M SO SERIOUS.
ALL THE BUSINESS YOU'VE DONE
IS, LIKE...
Herjavec: WOW.
CONGRATULATIONS.
THANK YOU, MARK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YEAH. GOOD JOB.
GOOD JOB, MR. CUBAN.
YES, SIR. IT'LL BE FUN.
THANK YOU.
THANKS.
Josh: THIS MEANS
THAT THE SKY'S THE LIMIT.
Diana: MARK AND ROBERT
ARE ANGEL INVESTORS.
THAT'S WHAT THEY ARE.
AND ANGELS
CAN GIVE YOU WINGS.
AND WITH WINGS,
YOU CAN FLY.
Narrator:
LAST SEASON, MELISSA CARBONE
LANDED THE LARGEST DEAL
IN "SHARK TANK" HISTORY --
$2 MILLION FROM MARK CUBAN
FOR HER HORROR-ENTERTAINMENT
COMPANY,
TEN THIRTY ONE PRODUCTIONS.
I WILL GIVE YOU $2 MILLION
FOR 40%.
CAN I COUNTER?
$2 MILLION FOR 20%.
I'LL TAKE THAT OFFER.
DONE.
REALLY?
YEP.
Narrator: LET'S SEE
HOW MELISSA IS DOING NOW.
NEXT!
[ GROWLING ]
Carbone: SINCE "SHARK TANK,"
OUR COMPANY HAS EXPLODED.
WE'RE FIRING ON ALL CYLINDERS.
IN OUR FIRST YEAR OF BUSINESS,
WE DID ABOUT $400,000
IN REVENUE.
SINCE OUR PARTNERSHIP WITH MARK,
WE'VE ACTUALLY SURPASSED
$2 MILLION IN REVENUE
AND ARE PLANNING TO DO BETWEEN
$3 MILLION AND $4 MILLION
IN REVENUE IN THE NEXT YEAR.
WHEN I WAS ON "SHARK TANK"
A YEAR AGO,
OUR COMPANY WAS KNOWN FOR
THE LOS ANGELES HAUNTED HAYRIDE.
NOW WE'RE ON TOUR
ACROSS THE NATION
WITH OUR NEWEST ATTRACTION,
THE GREAT HORROR CAMPOUT.
THE GREAT HORROR CAMPOUT
IS AN OVERNIGHT, 12-HOUR,
COMPLETELY INTERACTIVE
HORROR CAMPING ADVENTURE.
IT'S A SCAVENGER HUNT THAT SENDS
YOU DIVING INTO CADAVER BODIES
WHERE YOU MAY HAVE TO
BREAK RIBS, CLIP OFF FINGERS.
[ GROWLS ]
THERE ARE CHUPACABRAS
AND MOTHMEN AND DEMONS
AND PSYCHOPATHIC CLOWNS
WAITING TO MEET YOU.
WHOO!
[ HIGH-PITCHED SCREECH ]
ARE WE STOKED?
All: YES.
ALL RIGHT. YEAH.
WORKING WITH MARK
HAS BEEN INCREDIBLE.
HE INTRODUCED US TO THE C.E.O.
OF THE WORLD'S LARGEST
ENTERTAINMENT COMPANY,
LIVE NATION, AND THEY LIKED
OUR CONCEPT SO MUCH
THAT THEY INVESTED IN US, TOO.
ALL SUMMER LONG
TO GET TO THIS POINT
AND TO GET TO THIS CAST.
SINCE "SHARK TANK,"
OUR WHOLE CAST AND CREW
HAS TRIPLED TO ALMOST 1,000.
WITH MARK AND LIVE NATION
ON OUR TEAM,
THERE'S NOTHING STOPPING US
FROM BECOMING THE BIGGEST NAME
IN HORROR
AND LIVE ENTERTAINMENT.
I AM BEYOND THANKFUL
FOR MY "SHARK TANK" EXPERIENCE.
IT HAS GIVEN ME AN AWESOME
PARTNER, AMAZING RESOURCES,
AND THE ABILITY
TO BUILD THE COMPANY
I'VE ALWAYS SEEN IN MY HEAD.
[ ALL ROAR ]
Narrator:
NEXT INTO THE TANK
IS A FUN SPIN
ON A CLASSIC ACCESSORY.
HI. I'M DAN.
I'M DAVE.
AND I'M ERIC.
AND WE ARE H2W,
THE CREATORS OF SUN-STACHES,
A FUN AND EXCITING
FACEWEAR COMPANY.
WE ARE SEEKING $300,000
FOR A 5% EQUITY STAKE
IN OUR COMPANY.
WHOA.
WE ALL AGREE
ON ONE THING --
YOU DON'T WAIT FOR THE PARTY
TO COME TO YOU.
YOU BRING THE PARTY.
SOME BRING FOOD,
SOME OLIVE OIL.
BUT LET'S BE REAL.
[ LAUGHS ]
THE TIMES,
THEY ARE A-CHANGING,
AND THESE OLD GEMS
NEED AN EXTREME MAKEOVER.
HOW CAN ANYONE GET A PARTY
STARTED WITH THESE?
BORING!
SO WE DEVELOPED
A PROPRIETARY LINE
OF THE BEST PARTY SHADES
YOU'VE EVER SEEN --
SUN-STACHES.
THEY'RE MORE
THAN JUST EYEWEAR.
OH, MY GOD.
THEY'RE FACEWEAR.
WE HAVE A THEME STYLE
FOR EVERY OCCASION
FROM FOURTH OF JULY TO HANUKKAH
TO SPORTING EVENTS
AND EVEN
KIDS' BIRTHDAY PARTIES.
IMAGINE THESE
IN EVERY STADIUM!
WHOO!
AND IMAGINE THESE
IN EVERY RETAILER!
HYAH!
COME JOIN OUR PARTY.
AND WITH A LITTLE BIT
OF CASH,
WE CAN MAKE A WHOLE LOT
OF 'STACHE.
Herjavec: WHOO!
ALL RIGHT.
CAN WE TRY THEM?
ABSOLUTELY.
YES.
I'M CURIOUS TO SEE
WHAT YOU THINK WE ARE.
THERE YOU GO. ROBERT,
YOU'RE GONNA BE A COWBOY.
AND FEEL FREE TO PLAY
WITH THOSE SALOON DOORS.
THEY OPEN AND CLOSE.
LORI, YOU'RE GONNA BE
A BLACK CAT FOR HALLOWEEN.
AND, MR. WONDERFUL...
O'Leary: YES.
...WE OBVIOUSLY SELECTED
THE DEVIL FOR YOU...
OH, THANK YOU.
...FOR YOUR
DEVILISHLY HANDSOME LOOKS.
AND, DAYMOND, WE GOT THE PURPLE
FOOTBALL HELMET FOR YOU.
DAYMOND, PUT IT ON!
AND, MARK, YOU'RE GONNA
TRANSFORM INTO A LEPRECHAUN.
[ LAUGHTER ]
KEVIN,
LOOK OVER HERE.
YOU LOOK SO RIDICULOUS.
MARK, PUT YOURS ON.
NO, I DON'T THINK SO.
[ LAUGHS ]
SO, HAVE YOU SOLD
ANY OF THESE?
YES. LAST YEAR, WE ACTUALLY
DID $5.7 MILLION IN SALES.
OH.
WHOO!
THAT'S NO LAUGHING MATTER.
NOT SO FUNNY ANYMORE.
HOLD ON.
OF THAT, $2.8 MILLION
IS OUR BRAND OF SUN-STACHES.
THE REST IS OUR GENERIC
PRIVATE-LABEL GOODS.
ALL SUNGLASSES, RIGHT?
ALL SUNGLASSES, YEAH.
Greiner:
DO YOU SELL TO RETAILERS?
YES. OUR -- OUR MAJOR RETAILERS
ARE PARTY CITY, TOYS "R" US.
WE'RE MAINLY
IN SPECIALTY RETAIL.
GIVE ME AN IDEA HOW MUCH
THE COWBOY SELLS FOR.
ALL OUR PRODUCTS RANGE
FROM $7.99 TO $12.99.
AT RETAIL?
CORRECT.
OUR COST IS BETWEEN 75 CENTS
AND $1.50...
[ LAUGHS ]
WOW.
...DEPENDING ON COMPLEXITY
OF THE DESIGN AND WHATNOT.
THAT IS
A REALLY GOOD MARGIN.
WE'RE ON TRACK THIS YEAR
TO DO $6.4 MILLION IN SALES.
O'Leary:
AND YOU'LL MAKE, AFTER YOU PAY
YOURSELVES A NORMALIZED SALARY,
HOW MUCH?
WE'LL MAKE A PROFIT
OF ABOUT $750,000.
WOW.
GOOD FOR YOU GUYS.
HOW LONG
YOU BEEN DOING THIS?
WE'VE BEEN DOING SUN-STACHES
SINCE 2011.
O'Leary: FIRST OF ALL,
CONGRATULATIONS.
GREAT BUSINESS,
AND YOU'VE DONE A TERRIFIC JOB
ON ALL ASPECTS OF FUNCTION.
NOW THE SOBERING REALITY.
I'M TELLING YOU WHAT THE MARKET
WOULD TELL YOU YOU'RE WORTH,
JUST SO WE CAN SEE
IF THERE'S A DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN WHAT YOUR ASK WAS,
WHICH WAS $6 MILLION,
VERSUS WHAT, ON THE PLANET
EARTH, PEOPLE WOULD PAY FOR YOU.
SO, FIRST OF ALL, WE DO HAVE
AN ESTABLISHED BRAND.
YOU DON'T WANT
TO HEAR THIS NUMBER?
OH, I'M SORRY.
WHAT DO YOU THINK --
WHAT DO YOU THINK WE'RE WORTH?
I'M NOT CHARGING YOU
TO GIVE IT TO YOU.
PLEASE. PLEASE.
SOME FREE ADVICE.
YOU'RE WORTH
ABOUT 2.5 MILLION BUCKS.
OKAY, NEXT, I'M GONNA TELL YOU
ABOUT OUR PLAN FOR 2015
AND TELL YOU WHY I THINK
WE'RE WORTH MORE THAN THAT.
I'M GIVING YOU FIVE TIMES
YOUR AFTER-TAX CASH FLOW --
EXTREMELY GENEROUS OF ME.
I UNDERSTAND THAT.
WE GOT AN E-MAIL FROM TARGET
JUST SAYING,
"WE LOVE YOUR BRAND.
"WE SAW YOU IN THE MARKETPLACE,
WE WANT TO BRING YOU
IN ALL STORES."
NOW, WE ALSO
JUST GOT INTO LICENSING.
SO THIS IS HOW
WE'RE GONNA GROW.
WE WANT TO GROW TO MORE
LICENSING -- MARVEL, DC.
DAN, WHY DO YOU NEED
THE MONEY?
YOU DON'T NEED THE MONEY.
YOU BRING ME TO MY POINT.
SO, I TRIED TO GET
THESE LICENSES, RIGHT?
AND I GOT, LIKE,
"NO, WE'RE NOT INTERESTED."
NOW, HAVE YOU EVER CONSIDERED
LICENSING YOUR BUSINESS
TO SOMEBODY WHO HAS
ALL THESE PROPERTIES ALREADY?
SO, THIS IS WHERE THE IDEA OF
A STRATEGIC PARTNER COMES IN.
RIGHT NOW, THERE'S TWO MAJOR
PLAYERS IN LICENSED SPORTS,
AND BOTH OF THEM
WANT TO CARRY OUR LINE.
BUT WE KNOW IT'S GONNA
BE EXTREMELY LOW MARGIN
IF WE GO THROUGH THEM.
IF WE HAVE YOU AS A PARTNER AND
YOU SAY, "HEY, YOU KNOW WHAT?"
"LET'S PUT THE MONEY OUT.
LET'S DO --
GET THE LICENSING OURSELVES."
WAY HIGHER -- HIGHER MARGINS,
AND WE CAN BLOW IT UP THAT WAY.
WHY -- IF YOU FEEL THAT
THAT'S THE VALUE WE ADD,
WHY DO YOU MAKE US PAY A PREMIUM
FOR IT?
WHY ARE WE PAYING YOU
TO HELP YOU?
RIGHT.
I -- TO BE FRANK WITH YOU,
I DON'T THINK
WE'RE CHARGING THAT MUCH.
AT A $6 MILLION VALUATION
AND WITH THE GROWTH STRATEGY
THAT I OUTLINED,
I DO FEEL
IT'S A FAIR VALUE.
NOBODY'S GONNA PAY YOU
MORE THAN FIVE TIMES
YOUR CASH FLOW FOR THIS.
THEY JUST WON'T.
THE ONLY MISTAKE
YOU'VE MADE
IS YOU'VE -- YOU'VE PUT
A 100% PREMIUM ON IT,
AND YET YOU WANT A SHARK SO THAT
THEY CAN ADD THEIR VALUE.
VERY DIFFICULT TO DO THAT.
I MEAN, IT'S A --
IT'S A MISTAKE.
YOU'RE DOING EVERYTHING RIGHT,
OBVIOUSLY.
YOU'RE MAKING A LOT OF MONEY.
I CAN'T GET EXCITED
AND PASSIONATE ABOUT THESE.
JUST MY PERSONAL THING.
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME, LORI.
THANK YOU.
O'Leary: OKAY,
YOU LOST YOUR FIRST SHARK.
I DIDN'T HEAR YOU RE-ADJUST
YOUR VALUE, SO I'M OUT.
LET'S SEE IF YOU CAN
CONVINCE SOMEBODY ELSE
THAT YOU'RE WORTH
ANYTHING NEAR $6 MILLION.
GUYS, I-I-I...
I LOVE THE THREE OF YOU
AS OPERATORS.
VERY, VERY CLEVER DESIGN.
IT MADE ME LAUGH.
HERE'S MY CHALLENGE
WITH IT.
YOU'RE IN LOVE
WITH THE FUTURE.
I MEAN, YOU HAVE TO
BELIEVE IN THE FUTURE,
BUT YOU CAN'T
LOVE THE FUTURE SO MUCH
THAT IT CHANGES YOUR METRICS
OF TODAY.
I REALLY WISH THAT THERE WAS
A MORE REASONABLE VALUE
THAT YOU HAD
ON THIS BUSINESS.
JUST LIKE ANY GREAT LOVE AFFAIR,
YOU'VE GOT TO HAVE SOME SENSE
OF REALITY TO IT.
I'M OUT.
YOU HAVE TWO SHARKS LEFT.
YOU SHOULD FOCUS YOUR ENERGIES
ON THEM.
W-- YOU KNOW, WE --
WE WORKED PRETTY DAMN HARD
ON THESE THINGS.
WE'VE ALWAYS DONE
EXTREMELY WELL.
NO, I -- NO ONE'S QUESTIONING
YOUR EFFORT.
YOU GUYS ARE AMAZING.
WE'RE NOT SAYING THAT.
Levich: AND -- AND IF YOU FEEL
THE VALUATION ISN'T RIGHT,
WE'D LOVE TO HEAR AN OFFER.
LIKE, WE --
LOVE TO HEAR AN OFFER.
W-WE WANT TO GET AN --
WE'RE HERE TO MAKE A DEAL.
WE'RE NOT HERE, YOU KNOW,
FOR ANYTHING ELSE.
WHAT'S THE BEST EQUITY
YOU WOULD OFFER FOR $300,000?
THE RIGHT NUMBER IS 20%.
SO YOU'RE ASKING US TO VALUE
OUR COMPANY AT $1.5 MILLION?
I'M GIVING YOU
FREE ADVICE.
IF YOU WERE GOING
TO A PRIVATE-EQUITY FIRM,
THEY'D ASK FOR 15%.
BUT BECAUSE YOU WANT TO BRING
A SHARK IN, YOU PAY A PREMIUM.
THAT'S ANOTHER FIVE POINTS.
TRY 20%. MAYBE YOU GET THEM.
WOULD YOU BE WILLING TO DO
A DEAL FOR $300,000 FOR 10%?
NO.
OH, CRAZY. CRAZY.
A-A $3 MILLION VALUATION?
DO YOU HAVE ANOTHER --
DO YOU HAVE ANOTHER NUMBER?
WELL, ACTUALLY, KEVIN, YOU SAID
IT WAS WORTH $2.5 MILLION.
AT $3 MILLION, IT DOESN'T
SEEM THAT CRAZY, DOES IT?
I SEE YOU GUYS GOING
DOWN THE TOILET RIGHT NOW,
TO TELL YOU THE TRUTH --
YOU'RE ABOUT LOSE EVERYTHING.
Narrator:
THREE SHARKS ARE OUT.
DAYMOND AND MARK
MIGHT BE INTERESTED,
BUT THEY ARE NOT SATISFIED
EVEN THOUGH THE MAKERS
OF THE NOVELTY EYEWEAR COMPANY
SUN-STACHE
HAVE SLASHED THEIR VALUATION
FROM $6 MILLION TO $3 MILLION.
OKAY, GUYS,
YOU'VE ALREADY PROVEN
THAT YOU ARE GREAT DESIGNERS
AND YOU CAN WORK THIS OUT.
SO HERE'S WHERE I SEE IT --
I CAN HELP YOU GET
THE LICENSES YOU NEED,
ALSO GET THEM
AT REDUCED COST,
SO THAT'S WHERE
YOU'RE GONNA SAVE MONEY.
BUT I NEED TO GET PAID FOR THAT,
AND I NEED 25%.
YOW!
RIGHT THERE.
Herjavec: OOH.
BINGO.
AND THAT WILL SAVE YOU A LOT
OF TIME AND A LOT OF MONEY.
DAN,
I JUST WANT TO POINT OUT
THAT DAYMOND IS THE ONLY GUY
WHO MADE YOU THE OFFER.
MARK IS JUST ASKING YOU
TO NEGOTIATE AGAINST YOURSELF
AND THROW OFFERS AT HIM.
Cuban: IT'S TRUE.
O'Leary: SO...
YOU HAVE A FIRM OFFER,
AND IT'S GROUNDED IN REALITY.
ISN'T GRAVITY A BITCH?
DAYMOND,
I REALLY RESPECT YOUR OFFER,
BUT $300,000, PUTTING
OUR COMPANY AT $1.2 MILLION
WHEN WE MADE $570,000
LAST YEAR,
WE'RE ON TRACK TO MAKE $750,00
THIS YEAR --
AND YOU WILL BE ON TRACK
TO MAKE $20 MILLION AFTER THAT.
THAT VALUATION
I JUST THINK IS REALLY LOW.
WOULD YOU BE WILLING
MAYBE TO GO IN WITH MARK
FOR $300,000 FOR 12.5%?
I REALLY SEE THE VISION
WITH THE TWO OF YOU.
I THINK TWO SHARKS WOULD BE
GREAT -- MARK WITH THE SPORTS.
OH, I'M CLOSING THE BOOK.
I HATE DOING THAT.
I HATE WHEN I HAVE TO
CLOSE THE BOOK.
MARK, WOULD YOU BE WILLING,
PERHAPS,
TO GO $300,000
FOR LIKE 12.5%?
GUYS, NO.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
I'M NOT GONNA DO 12.5%.
I'M OUT.
YOU'RE OUT.
Herjavec: ERIC, DON'T YOU THINK
IT'S A LITTLE ODD
THAT ONE GUY MADE YOU AN OFFER
AND YOUR REBUTTAL WAS TO MARK?
DAYMOND, WOULD YOU BE WILLING
TO DO $300,000 FOR 15%?
I THINK
THAT PUTS US AT ABOUT --
DID YOU JUST OFFER MARK 12.5%
BUT DAYMOND 15%?
THAT'S WHAT HE DID.
John: WELL, HE'S SAVING HIMSELF
RIGHT NOW.
IT'S OKAY.
HE JUST -- HE JUST GAVE HIMSELF
A LITTLE BIT OF MOUTH-TO-MOUTH.
WE CAME HERE
TO MAKE A DEAL.
I WOULD NORMALLY CHARGE SOMEBODY
30% FOR MY SERVICES.
SO I'LL MEET YOU AT 20%.
AND I NEED THE ANSWER NOW, GUYS.
WE CAN'T TAKE FOREVER.
'CAUSE THAT MEANS, THEN,
YOU'RE NOT DEFINITIVE
IN REGARDS TO DECISIONS
YOU HAVE TO MAKE.
WOULD YOU DO 17%?
NO.
Gershon: DAYMOND...
LET'S MAKE IT HAPPEN,
CAP'N.
ALL RIGHT.
[ BOTH LAUGH ]
Gershon: THIS IS FOR YOU.
OH, THAT WAS PAINFUL.
Greiner: GOOD DEAL.
THAT WAS BRUTAL.
THANKS, MAN. WE'RE REALLY
EXCITED TO WORK WITH YOU.
THANK YOU, MAN. A'IGHT.
SO EXCITED.
THANKS, GUYS.
APPRECIATE IT.
Greiner: GOOD LUCK.
ENJOY THAT.
Cuban: GOOD LUCK, GUYS.
THANK YOU.
Gershon: THANKS A LOT, GUYS.
OH, THOSE LOOK GOOD ON YOU.
Herjavec:
YEAH, THEY DO LOOK GOOD ON YOU.
[ LAUGHS ]
WE DID IT.
WHOO!
ALL RIGHT, GUYS.
I THINK THAT'S THE FIRST TIME
WE'VE HAD SOMEBODY START AT 5%
AND NEGOTIATE THEMSELVES
UP TO 20%.
THEY JUST KEPT
THROWING OUT NUMBERS.
I LIKE THEM A LOT.
I WAS READY TO GO DOWN
TO 19.5%.
SO, EVEN THOUGH
WE DIDN'T GET
THE VALUATION
WE WERE ASKING FOR,
WE GOT A SHARK, AND HE WANTS
TO BLOW UP OUR BUSINESS.
AND HE SAID IT HIMSELF -- "I'M
GONNA MAKE YOU $20 MILLION."
AND WE BELIEVE THAT.
WE BELIEVE.
IT'S GONNA HAPPEN.
HELL, YEAH.
YEP.
THAT'S GONNA HAPPEN.